they'll take their swings off to 28 year
old spencer watkins making his ninth
start of the year ready with the 2-2
pitch
and he got him
down on strikes ohtani out number one
look where savarino set up on the
outside part now i'm telling you you
can't do it any better than that one
really good start for watkins it is
dylan bundy on the mound for the angels
the next 2-2 from bundy got him on a
fastball here's ryan mout castle 21
homer 65 driven in
that's hit well
deep into the left field corner that is
gone
ryan mobcastle
jumps on the dylan bundy pitch
the orioles lead it one to nothing mount
castle number 22. he hammered it ben
got him
[Applause]
changed locations of the fastball nicely
to get out of any further trouble the
homer opens the scoring however one
nothing orioles all starts off the
second
strike three
middle of the plate also is expecting
something different and it's the second
strike out of the game for watkins
and stassi lines the base hit back up
the middle
max went over seven in the cleveland
series so he's back on track with a
knock in his first at-bat here in
baltimore marsh digging in with two
runners aboard and one man out
instead he smacks that one into the gap
in left center field here comes iggy
around to score
and the angels have counter punch tying
it up in the second
and here's joe adele now the o2 to adele
that's into center field mullins can't
corral it it's over his glove and all
the way to the wall here comes stassi to
score
marsh right behind him adele all the way
to third three to one halos and now the
orioles are going to bring the infield
in with a runner at third and one gone
in a three to one game in the second
inning for juan legarres
legarres drives a ball to left and that
one's gonna go
one gone
two run shot
five to one halos how can you explain
the pitcher
gets the first basically five guys out
with relative ease and then you look up
now you're down five to one
bounce to short mateo has it
and the innings over but not before the
angels do some major damage put five up
they're on top five one
and a called strike three taken by
severino bundy rings him up on three
pitches
change up got him look it and he's
removed 46 pitches into the start in
favor of right-hander junior guerra who
inherits the bases loaded with only one
away
back up the middle
fletcher's got it
and houdini
guerra
is out of the jam in the second so
gosselin leaves things off in the halo
third and here's the pitch and that's a
shot in the left field that's going to
fall in for a base hit
phil gosling is on
here's walsh now rung up on strikes in
his first try
and there's a base hit into right center
so the third inning opening the same way
the second started station to station
knox and the angels have runners at the
corners with nobody out here's jose
iglesias now connor wade is up for the
orioles iglesias sends that one to left
that's over hayes gosselin will walk in
to score an rbi double for jose iglesias
so now with dell with one gun a run in
and still the base is loaded here's the
3-2 to adele
into center field a flare that's going
to score at least one walsh has waved
around to score here's iggy right behind
him a two-run single for joe adele make
it a four-rbi start to the night for the
angels rookie
blind drive right to jones soft line
drive this time and it ends the inning
but not before the angels add on three
more 8-1 la ball to anthony santander he
bounced out to second his only at-bat
and mentioned him being healthy battling
that ankle rips one into right field all
the way to the scoreboard anthony around
first and in with a double he's had some
nice swings lately here's urias
there's the line drive and it's a fair
ball into the right field corner
santander will score maria's hustles the
second and he's in with an rbi double
and now it's an eight-two game so here's
iglesias once again he has scored two of
the eight runs tonight
and that one's down in front of hayes
gosselin scores it's nine to two angels
still nobody out first and second with
the run in now for max stassi
and max sends the ball out to right
center field that one's well hit off the
wall
walsh will come in to score it's an rbi
double for stassi and it's 10-2 halos
so the next batter at the plate is
lagarris and he swings and lines one
into right center field that's going to
drive in another run and the angels will
have runners at first and third and now
it is 12 to 2.
that's
it pretty well to right field but room
no it's off the wall trying to deep
mancini not gonna work trey around third
has the green light he's headed for the
plate and he'll score santander with a
second double to the game and an rbi
so a couple out there for raymond urias
who doubled one in his last at-bat
there's a base hit maurice has done it
again
one run in austin hayes gets the green
light and it's a two rbi base hit for
ramona reyes who's driven in three in
the game now ryan mal castle now leads
the orioles and home runs and rbis
that's hit well
deep right field and it's in the flag
court his second home run of the game
ryan castle swinging a hot stick
number 23.
[Applause]
santander with a blast way back
two-run shot
out onto utah street don't go anywhere
folks
oh boy
so here's fletch now he has a base
hitting an rbi tonight first and second
with two gone
slider bounced up the middle another rbi
for fletch tonight mullins boxes it in
center oh johnny to third he is an rbi
machine so cedric mullins last chance
for baltimore tonight
and after a series against the indians
where the angels scored a total of two
runs in three games they put up 14 runs
on 19 hits tonight to send the baltimore
orioles to their 19th consecutive loss